This is a bit different for a Sixty Symbols video in that
actually it's a sort of meta-video
in that is not actually about science, it's
about sixty symbols itself and the
exciting news is that there is the
opportunity for somebody new to get
involved in the whole project
somebody to come and join the team start
making some of the videos start doing
some science
the whole point of this series is that
they're kind of bits of science being
described by scientists and so we do
want somebody who is a professional
scientist getting involved in this but
what's a bit different about it is that
you'll notice most of the people doing
the videos are getting on a bit these
days we've been doing them for a while
and so what's exciting about this is
we're gonna get somebody at a much
earlier stage in a scientific career
involved in the whole project so that
not only can they talk about the science
but obviously one of the questions we
get asked quite a lot of the time is you
know what's it like to be starting out
of the career in science for us that was
all a fair while ago
so having somebody who's actually going
to that process now could talk about
what it's like to be starting in a
career in science as well as talking
about the science itself is part of what
we're trying to do so it's called the
sixty symbols ogden fellowship is what
we've managed to create and there are
different parts of that
so let's start at the back end
fellowship basically means this is a
postdoctoral researcher who can do
whatever they like
so kind of the distinction between just the general postdoc and a
fellow is that fellows really dictate
their own research programs so we want somebody
to come in who's going exciting ideas
about what science they want to be doing
anywhere within physics or astronomy
this is a real research position you
know it's going to be to get two-thirds
of the time doing research one third of
the time maybe doing outreach-type
things but it's fundamentally a proper
research position and very exciting
opportunity because as i say the
person is coming in really will get to
to define what their research program is
so that's the fellowship bit the bit in
the middle ... uh well the bit at the beginning
is sixty symbols that's the easy bit
the bit in the middle the ogden bit is
because obviously this takes money and
we've been looking around trying to find
somebody to support this idea and the
ogden trust which is a charitable trust
that kind of promotes physics in the UK
has agreed to fund partly fund the
position
so part of the job will actually be
supporting the kind of the ogden trust's
agenda of getting out in the community
talking about physics encouraging groups
of people who don't typically go into
scientific careers to go into scientific
careers
what are they going to
have to do with sixty symbols or do we
well I guess I have some say in that too
you'd probably get to say about that i mean my
initial idea was really that they just
they fit in with the team so they start
making the kind of videos that we make
generally obviously they'll bring their
own particular interest so hopefully
some new areas of physics that we
haven't been covering but also to talk
more generally about what they're up to
what it's like to be doing the job that
they're doing you know when they start
applying for their own funding and those
kinds of things they can talk about all
that just talking about things from that
early career perspective that the rest
of us don't really have a little feature
in the videos and you know if they have
particular skills they want to bring to
bear that we don't currently use then
that would be fine too
so it is a postdoctoral position which
means that one of the requirements of
the post is you have to have a PhD
that's that's really it though and so
we're looking for somebody who's
probably just at the point of completing
a PhD now or completed it within the
last year or so who's looking for their
first sort of serious research position
I want an astronomer but that's just because I'm an
astronomer and if you talk to Phil
Moriarty he wants a you know
a nice nanotechnologist so I'm sure
we all have our own idea as to exactly the
right person for the job is but there
is no there is no there is no set person
though is there?
there is no real... no there's no
agenda no hidden agenda here we haven't
got somebody lined up already it's a
completely open competition when we are
appointing postdoctoral researchers the
main thing we look at is you know their
CV and publication list and all those
kinds of things are going to ask for all
those those things but obviously this is
a bit different and so the other thing
we're asking people to do is to make a
video themselves
no more than two minutes duration just
explaining some piece of science they do
not really not necessarily in the style
of sixty symbols but kind of at the level
of sixty symbols so just to kind of
demonstrate they have that ability to
explain what they're doing in the kind
of way that we explain things
and the other thing to stress about that
is when we come to kind of assess those
videos
we're not going to look at the technical
quality of your... you know assuming the
video is viewable and the sounds audible
and those kinds of things we really not
going to be critiquing them because you
know we have an entirely adequate
cameraman [laughing] so
was that you said? [laughing] the position is funded
the two years so it's a two-year
position
obviously we're hoping that it will be a
huge success and everyone will be falling all
over themselves to continue funding it
but it will be guaranteed for two years
at least you know a lot of reasons why
we're excited about this it's a new
thing with pushing the project in new
directions
it's an opportunity to do some new
science and I guess what's most exciting
about that is it's an opportunity to do
new science that wouldn't have happened
at all if it wasn't for sixty symbols so
actually the science that comes out of
this is science that wouldn't have been
done if it weren't for the sixty symbols
videos
so which i think is really quite
exciting aspect of the whole thing
yeah me too
vastly restrict the amount of light
coming in to isolate exactly the
wavelengths that we want
so it turns our wide filter into a
filter with a width of just a nanometer
or so and it's tunable so it's got two
little plates inside a reflecting
material